el comediante stephen wright al cual
creo podemos también decir que es un
filósofo una ocasión comentó que los
hoyos negros eran el lugar donde dios
dividió entre 0 y no me quiero meter con
física para esto pues como sabes la
metáfora se rompería en diversas formas
pero extrañamente apropiada porque los
agujeros negros son justo el lugar donde
la física comienza a romperse y dividir
entre cero aunque parezca una simple
idea es donde las matemáticas también se
rompen esto es indefinido y el término
indefinido parece algo muy bizarro en
una simple clase de matemáticas como una
simple idea pero en realidad significa
lo que exactamente la palabra significa
los matemáticos nunca dijeron o
definieron que era dividir entre cero o
que era ese valor y la razón por la que
lo hicieron es porque no pueden
encontrar una respuesta buena o no había
una respuesta adecuada para dicha
definición y por eso cualquier número
dividido
entre 0 se deja simplemente como
indefinido 7 / 08 / 0 -1 entre 0 decimos
que son simplemente cosas indefinidas
ahora podrías decir hey si no podemos
definirlo al menos podríamos intentar
llegar a algún tipo de definición así
que vamos a intentarlo y podemos tomar
el número de los más sencillos que sería
en este caso el 1 aunque en realidad tú
puedes tomar cualquier número distinto
de 0 y lo vamos a dividir entre un
número muy pequeño y positivo que se
acerque a 0 y vamos a ver qué pasaría si
lo dividimos entre 0.1 y bien esto al
dividirlo entre 0.1 nos dará 10 luego si
dividimos uno entre punto 0 1 esto nos
dará 100 y así nos acercamos más con
números muy muy cercanos a cero como
0.000 0 1 lo cual nos dará esta es una
respuesta de 1 entre bueno eso sería una
millonésima
dividido entre esto sería igual a un
millón por lo que si te das cuenta aquí
tenemos un patrón si dividimos uno entre
un número muy pequeño y cada vez más
pequeño y positivo obtendremos un número
cada vez más grande por lo que basado en
esto podríamos decir que tenemos una
cercana definición que cuando dividimos
entre un número muy pequeño esto se
acerca a más infinito pues entre más
números pequeños positivos estemos
tomando obtenemos números cada vez más
grandes pero luego un amigo podrá llegar
y decirte bueno esto funciona para
números muy pequeños pero positivos
cercanos a cero pero qué pasaría con
números negativos y cercanos a cero así
que ahora tratemos con esto 1 entre
menos 0.1 y nos da menos 10 1 entre
menos 0.01 lo cual nos da menos 100 y 1
entre menos punto 0 0001 lo cual nos va
a dar
menos un millón por lo que si seguimos
dividiendo uno entre números negativos
que son cada vez más próximos a cero
tendremos una respuesta muy diferente de
hecho nos estaremos acercando a menos
infinito así que habíamos dicho que por
acá se llama más infinito pero se puede
dar un resultado o un argumento igual de
fuerte que diga que esto es número sería
muy distinto de hecho será menos
infinito exactamente opuesto a más
infinito por lo que puedes hacer el
mismo argumento fuerte para esto y es
por eso que los matemáticos han dicho
que no hay una buena respuesta para esto
y entonces que ninguno de estos valores
sería consistente con otros valores que
conocemos así que por eso ellos han
dicho este asunto se resuelve como algo
indefinido y listo
indefinido